[Music]
since its discovery in 1610 by Galileo
the rings of Saturn have enchanted us
for centuries remarkably we've visited
Saturn before stunning photographs taken
from the Cassini space probe have
revealed that Saturn's rings are much
more complex than you might think so
what would it be like to actually go in
person how long would it take you to
travel to Saturn what would you see
along the way and could you survive in
Saturn's rings this is what if and
here's what would happen if you jumped
into Saturn's rings
on October 15th 1997 NASA the European
Space Agency and the Italian space
agency banded together to change the
history of astronomy their mission was
to study the Saturn system a diverse mix
of stellar objects made up of rocks ice
and several moons together they
developed the space probe Cassini
Huygens which was propelled on a
seven-year journey to Saturn let's
imagine we had the technology to bring
you traveller along for the ride what
kind of adventure are you in for well
luckily we're taking the scenic route
after a year of drifting through space
and saying goodbye to earth our first
stop is Venus don't worry this isn't a
layover
we're merely visiting the outer edge of
Venus's orbit giving you a gravitational
speed boost as you pass by this will
allow you to save on fuel and take in
the view of Venus a swirling scenery
after the first orbit you'll get a nice
boost of seven kilometers per second but
we'll need one more journey around it
for the optimal speed boost this time
we'll be about 600 kilometers from Venus
I hope you have a strong stomach
traveler as the gravitational pull might
be like that time you ate funnel cake
before going on that spinny ride at the
fair hello never again
after a quick spin around Venus
you'll be slingshotted towards Mars and
Jupiter but this part of the ride might
get a little bumpy so buckle up you're
about to pass through an asteroid belt
fortunately the chances of hitting an
asteroid are pretty slim as they are
very spread apart unlike what you see in
the movies still you never know just be
prepared to take manual control in case
your proximity sensors malfunction once
you've made it through the scary part
it's fairly smooth sailing from here on
out sit back and admire the view on your
right in the distance you'll see the red
planet Mars and on your left is Jupiter
look that tiny speck orbiting the gas
giant is the Galileo spacecraft a small
yet welcome reminder of home at this
point it's been almost five years Wow
how time flies when you're being hurled
through space saturn is our next stop
but is it safe
we're about to find out after waiting a
couple of years doing lots of Sudoku and
re watching all your favorite what-if
videos we've finally arrived in orbit of
Saturn surprisingly the flat and solid
ring structure you've seen in pictures
back home you're way off these rings are
complex systems of orbits subdivided by
several different sections each of these
rings are separated by gaps made from
over 60 of Saturn's moons the Rings are
made up of chunks of ice and rock some
as small as little boulders and some as
big as houses these are the remnants of
comets asteroids meteoroids and
shattered moons torn apart by Saturn's
gravity all right traveller it's time
for a spacewalk you probably won't have
much success walking on Saturn's rings
unless you happen to land on one of its
moons like Metheny Pelini or even Titan
which has been considered a potential
site for a future space colony but
you'll want to keep your spacesuit on as
Titan is a chilly minus 170 nine point
six degrees Celsius at this point you're
almost twice the distance between the
Earth and the Sun now for the moment of
truth
the grand finale as we approach the
final rings of Saturn we'll have to fly
through them on a careful trajectory
orbiting Saturn 22 times to get our best
travel shots here you'd be only 2,000
kilometers away from Saturn's atmosphere
after about 20 years in space you'd
reach Saturn's interior
let's be honest you'd likely
disintegrate but thankfully you were
careful and managed to hang around on
Titan instead leaving the Cassini probe
to do the rest of the work the amount of
data
Cassini managed to send back to earth is
truly spellbinding making it one of
humankind's greatest success stories in
astronomy maybe on our next voyage we
could take a closer look at Saturn's big
brother Jupiter but not too close
because well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]